we do have an invasion driven by the
cartels we've turned back
tens of thousands of migrants who try to
get across the border i
would suggest that
so-called leaders
focus on solutions
instead of attacks
so-called leader well vice president and
border czar kamala harris is tearing
into texas governor greg abbott after he
defied the biden administration and took
matters into his own hands to address
the migrant crisis south carolina
congresswoman nancy mace joins us now
you heard those two sound bites there
seems to me like governor greg abbott
has a solution when kamala harris says
where's the solution it's right in front
of you kamala where is her solution
congresswoman
that is the question i think every
american whether you're on the southern
border or not would like an answer to
kamala harris has no solution to the
border which is why she's obviously
lashing out at governor abbott and thank
you thank god for governor abbott having
some solutions having some creative way
to approach the border security issues
that we're having having millions of
illegal immigrants come across the
border last year alone at least there's
somebody paying attention to our
borderless governor greg abbott because
certainly it's not vice president kamala
harris certainly it's not president joe
biden or anyone in his administration at
this point a new report a leaked report
actually finds that the u.s is bracing
for more than 160 thousand unaccompanied
children at the border this year also
there's a record number of people coming
from 150 different countries across the
world the u.n just named the u.s mexico
border the most dangerous border
crossing in the entire world a record
number of drugs and guns also pouring
into the country also 50
people on the terror watch list
were apprehended trying to get into the
country which begs the question how many
people on that watch list have entered
the country and we don't know about them
all of these things congresswoman seem
like they should be issues of bipartisan
concern
why is the border issue so partisan
it should be issues of bipartisan
concern it should be an issue or
priority number one or number two
priority after inflation for the
president of the united states i've been
to the border i've seen dozens of people
coming across illegally and the night
that i was there this year and last year
it is a huge problem look at the
fentanyl coming across the border what
is joe biden and kamala harris what are
they doing about that i just had someone
that attended a funeral of a young man
that died of a fentanyl overdose i mean
this is happening in our communities
every community and every state across
the country and what is the
administration doing absolutely nothing
which is why you're going to see a giant
red wave in november why it's important
to back republicans who have solutions
republicans like governor greg abbott
and others along the border and others
in congress that have solutions to this
looming crisis that's getting worse and
worse by the day to another
controversial issue abortion joe biden
stopping his bike ride to urge women to
keep protesting abortion ruling as he
reveals he's looking into whether he can
declare it a public health emergency
take a listen
keep protesting because keep making your
point
it's critically important we can do a
lot of things
to accommodate
the rights of women
in the meantime but fundamentally the
only thing that's going to change this
is if we have a national law
biden is getting a lot of pushback from
the far left to his response they said
it didn't go far enough so where does
joe biden go with this does he cave to
the far left on yet another topic i.e
abortion and if so what does that look
like congresswoman
he's caved to the far left on every
single issue but we've got it we've got
to be factual here it was democrats when
joe biden was vice president obama was
president they had an opportunity with a
super majority they had the house they
had this in it they could have codified
a made into law
row but they they decided not to and
they used it as a juggernaut to
fundraise for the last several years and
now we've seen aoc and others online on
twitter lying about what roe v wade
overturning it actually does and doesn't
do
and we're seeing a lot of pressure but
biden every single time they've asked
him to turn over he's taken that sharp
left turn to the other side and it's
going to have devastating consequences
for the democrat party in november in 22
and also in 24. yeah president biden
said as todd said he's looking into
declaring a public health emergency
over abortion rights there's still a lot
of questions over what that might look
like and i guess we'll be learning in
the coming days exactly what that could
mean whether it's funding or something
else entirely congresswoman nancy may
thank you so much for joining us this
morning we appreciate it as always
thank you always